let's talk a little bit about kind of
the general state of some of these
technologies so let's start with the
voice recognition in general kind of
give us an update as to where that is as
an industry and then kind of how you see
that developing over the next ten years
or so yeah that's mnDOT's takes for each
of the major cloud vendors so that's
where it is today I mean you can still
be surprised by certain applications of
the technology so for instance everybody
assumed that text to speech was
commoditized but in the last week Google
announced a novel implementation where
to backfill video conferencing they
actually took portions of your own voice
synthesized it and they would insert
them phonemes into these video
conferencing feeds so that you wouldn't
have dropouts for instance so you have
these sort of little applications that
are moving the ball forward but none of
the grand big bang style innovations
anymore in that in that particular field
especially post 2012 so it's easier than
ever to build new languages obviously
you know you need to have a clean signal
and do as best as you can now you match
models and you pair it with machine
translation and at some point in time
you'll you'll expect where you could be
an interview in in in Russian in Chinese
and French and and talking to me and in
your earpiece you'll hear it in your
native language and vice versa but you
know there's still some areas where
we're language processing is still a
little bit iffy and that's all the
metaphors that we tend to use and and
the jest that we tend to use and the
fact that language is constantly
evolving with slang and so that's a
never-ending part of the work but the
big breakthroughs are are elsewhere
nowadays yeah one of the things I've
been very surprised that both positively
at some point and also negatively is
podcast transcripts right just having
done so many of them everyone in their
mom has come to us and said hey look at
you know we've got this tool that can
basically take the audio record
transcribe it and the best ones are
still like the googles of the world
right I mean people who are specifically
focused on podcast audio to text they're
just not very high quality right and
what ends up happening to your point is
either one they're too literal right so
every time I say the word right like and
um and all these things get kind of
ingested in and so you get kind of a non
clean version or they just miss words
right and it's actually the conversion
from audio to text it's something pretty
surprising but then it does it on the
other side it's not as surprising
because Google probably has one of the
best ones from what we see well because
they were incentive to create one of the
best ones right because they actually
developed it to operate on YouTube so
that they can figure out what was in the
video so that they can pair the best ads
right so where there's a will there's a
way
right there are basically two major
places where media mining you know gets
perfected one is in the ad space and the
second is in the intelligence community
monitoring you know television
broadcasts in the case of voicemails for
instance one of the things that we
discovered is that you know when we used
to leave more voicemails and there were
a lot of voicemails on our previous
platforms we would rewrite a spoken
English into written English and part of
that was to remove those pause words
like you mentioned the ohms and AHS and
things of that sort yeah super
interesting machine learning what uh
what's kind of the lay of the land or
you know a state of where that
technology is and then how do you see
that playing out over the next 10 years
or so yeah I think it's more than
applications of it right so and there's
a lot of work being done in that space
certainly in the academic environment
but you have to let me relate it to to
the past so according to be Marilyn
Wright is a fantastic school for speech
recognition and they have this academic
engine called Sphinx but for the most
part you know it's there for anybody to
download but you can't really put that
into into production right it doesn't
have the accuracy the scale in their
resilience that's in an optimization is
necessary to ever be put in in ahead a
large-scale implementation right and so
it's the same thing right
maybe hearing about all of these
advancements in in deep learning and and
in natural language processing and
what-have-you but in order to take that
work that research and all the ideas
that you're hearing and actually put it
in such a way and package them so that
they could be consumed by these
large-scale enterprises with you know
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
or billions of transactions per month
that's a totally different thing and
frankly you have to start from scratch
in in many places